[Music]
hey everyone it's Jonah here so I've put
together a four week belly fat challenge
for you nope we are not doing 100
crunches okay we know that we cannot
spot reduce fat
hence doing 100 of 1000 crunches every
single they were not work this workout
will be combining core exercises to
really strengthen your core and also
cardio exercises to elevate your heart
rate and also to burn that belly fat a
layer off for the first and second week
the goal is to complete two sets for the
third and fourth week we want to
challenge yourself even more and
complete three sets
so this workout will be based on
repetitions and also time I'm good to
take you through each week let's do it
so let's start with the exercises for
week 1 and also week 3 the aim is to
complete 25 repetitions for each
exercise first full extension fully
extend both arms and legs straight out
crunch in and bring your knees to with
the chest and arms touching the ankles
by lifting your shoulders slightly off
the floor you will feel the upper and
lower abs engaged only lower your legs
as far as you can without arching your
lower back beginners you can bend your
knees slightly
this next exercise is my favorite half
of the attacks support your upper body
and keep your shoulders relaxed keep
both legs together engage your lower abs
and lift them straight up towards the
ceiling then slowly lower down your legs
close to the floor and lift them back up
the guiness again you can choose to keep
your knees slightly bent now let's move
on and focus on your cardio let's do
jump squats stand shoulder width apart
push your butt back and lower yourself
into a deep squat using the force from
your legs lift your body off the floor
into a jump land gently keeping your
knees bent remember to push from your
heels not from your toes okay
this exercise will elevate your heart
rate and burn that stubborn belly fat
let's get back down onto the floor and
do the fourth core exercise four times
apps we want to alternate by lifting and
lowering one leg at a time don't rest
your heels on the floor throughout the
workout so you have to really keep your
core engaged
this continuous motion will create
tension on your lower abs and trust me
you will feel the burn this next workout
focuses on your obliques windshield
wiper to keep your upper body in
position spread both arms out to your
sides now bring both legs straight up
and lower them down to the left side in
a slow and controlled manner using your
core strength bring both legs back to
the center and then lower to the
opposite side to fully engage your
obliques keep your upper body in
position at all times and we want to end
a circuit with another cardio bursting
workout your favourite burpees if you're
a beginner you can choose not to jump
and simply step up aim to complete 25
repetitions in the shortest time
possible
don't stop okay keep your heart rate
elevated and only take one minute break
once you have completed the entire
circuit now let's move on to week two
and for the exercises will be time-based
we want to do each workout for 30
seconds with 10 seconds rest in between
there will be lots of plank exercises
for this week so the first exercise is
plank hip dip get into a solid plank
position keeping your back flat and body
in a straight line
dip your hip to the left and to the
right in a controlled manner avoid
arching your lower back or piking your
butt up so you really have to tighten
your core keep going for 30 seconds stay
strong alright this is your first
workout next spider-man plank get into a
high plank position pumps directly under
your shoulders in a straight line
keeping your elbows slightly bent
bring your right knee towards your right
elbow return to plank position
and alternate on the other side if you
want
killer abs do this let's move on to a
cardio based core exercise plank jacks
so maintain at the high plank position
jump both legs out to a wide stance and
jump both legs back in again when you're
performing plank exercises always
remember to keep your back flat so no
arching or piking your butt up in the
air suck your belly in this will really
give you a strong core working on a core
strength it does not always mean big
movements just by holding a certain
position it can strengthen those deep
core muscles
so the fourth core workout is half the
boot keep your chest up back flat and
lean back slightly lift both legs off
the floor and keep your knees slightly
bent toes pointed maintain this position
for 30 seconds and I want you to clap
your hands up and under your legs next
lie flat on your back keeping your hands
by your head lift your shoulders and
both legs few inches off the floor the
move your legs up and down in a
fluttering motion keep the movement
small this will make your lower abs work
a lot harder beginners you can choose to
rest your shoulders and head on the mat
and the final workout will be another
cardio based exercise Kronus I love and
hate this workout it is so effective but
extremely tiring at the same time start
in a high plank position and bring your
right leg close to your right pump as
you jump your right leg back
simultaneously jump your left leg
forward bringing it close to your left
pump don't stop this will elevate your
heart rate and you will be burning lots
of calories and of course burning the
stubborn belly fat beginners you can
remove the jumping motion and just step
forward and back alternating between the
legs always keep you
chest open and look forward so these are
all the exercises for week two and four
again the aim is to complete at least
two circuits in week two and increase
that to three to four circuits in week
four of course you can take a one-minute
rest in between circuits if you're a
beginner then take a longer rest and to
do this challenge every day all right
you can end your workout with this
challenge if you keep this routine
consistent you will get stronger and you
will see the difference in four weeks be
sure to like this video share and
challenge your friends subscribe to my
youtube channel for more workout videos
and workout challenges do also turn on
your notification button so that you
won't get notified every time I share a
new video all the best